Give me a second while I nurse my baby
so that I can respond to this very ignorant comment.
So this must be the most ignorant comment I've ever gotten,
and I've gotten a lot of those.
I really hope, ma'am,
that you don't have a daughter you're giving advice to
and you give stay at home moms a bad name.
The literal definition of a stay at home mom is a mom who stays home.
There are women who run their own businesses,
who work remotely,
and who have side hustles that are still stay at home moms.
Second, you don't know my financial situation,
so don't ever make a bold Assumption like that.
With my first son, when I quit my corporate job,
I 100% stopped doing everything and just stayed home,
including my side hustles.
But I also built my social media like six years ago
because I knew the impact of digital marketing
and its projected growth
and how it could help so many women just like me
monetize social media
so that they could stay home with their children if they need to.
Some make full incomes from it,
I do not. Some make a little extra money here and there.
Most of my stuff at this point is passive
from what I built before I had kids.
And occasionally I repurpose a video.
99% of the things that I recommend to women who wanna work from home
and I direct them towards I Absolutely
make zero money off of actually lose time from talking to them
and trying to figure out what fits their personality best,
because I've done it all. But I do it because it's a passion of mine.
And I post videos like this when my children are asleep.
It's crazy that I'm not a stay at home mom.
Um, even though I,
like, co slept and nursed my baby all night,
I woke up at the butt crack of dawn with both of them.
I work 24 hours and weekends and holidays,
and I literally don't leave my home.
It's crazy. The whole reason I started digital marketing
and monetizing social media,
especially when I work in the financial industry,
was because I knew one day I wanted to stay home.
So when I was in college, I literally said,
what is an industry that I know is flexible,
that I know I can be my own boss,
and that I know I can make either a full time salary or even part time,
or maybe just a side hustle and extra hundred bucks a week.
I put a lot of thought into that way early on,
into my early 20s, because I knew what I wanted.
And back then, before I had kids,
I was absolutely hundred percent monetizing social media.
But regarding your other comment about how I get paid from TikTok,
absolutely have never received a dime from these videos
from any platform.
All I've done Is create a community of like minded people.
And the hair products that I represent,
it's definitely just affiliate marketing,
definitely not a pyramid scheme.
You literally know nothing.
I have reoccurring customers who just buy the product.
I have no one that works the business for me or under me.
And if they do want to, they approach me about it.
I don't advertise or market it.
And from that,
I'll make right now looks like an extra hundred dollars a week.
Sometimes like 60 bucks a week.
But when you're cloth diapering and you're eating alcohol year,
and you are clipping coupons,
and you're living within your means,
an extra 60, 50 bucks a week goes a long way.
So just because I bring in a little extra side money,
does not mean I am not a real stay at home mom.
So you stop. And pertaining to your man.
God, I feel bad for him.
My man absolutely provides for all of our needs.
I am fed, clothed,
and I have a roof over my head.
And both my babies are taken care of.
Sorry, I had like a 6,
7 hour intermission. Apparently we're all getting sick.
And I take care of babies and clean.
Before the men came back from hunting anyway.
Ma'am,
just because a woman has a side hustle,
or brings in extra bucks here and there,
or even if she worked for Molly,
it does not make her any less of a Stay at home, mom.
So, like,
honest to god, now that I'm seven hours later finishing this video,
I'm like, why do I even give you the time of day?
It's this. That's the stupidest thing I've ever heard in my life.
Um. Oh, yeah.
And as far as my Instagram, again,
started that years ago, and I honestly don't even post on it anymore.
I mainly just through my stories.
So you would know that, though,
if you actually, like,
followed me and knew me. But you're not.
You're just a troll.
Have a good day.